each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay uh is my extreme pleasure today to
introduce these three gentlemen I have
here before me in the front row um I've
worked with all of them since about
nineteen ninety six ish seven ish in
fact the gentleman the middle yeah
interviewed me so it's all his fault
they've they've all done amazing things
Michael Cohen is a principal researcher
in the interactive visual media group
spend here for 16 years since leaving
Princeton University where he was a
faculty member he sits at the
intersection between computer graphics
and computer vision but I would say now
dare I say you dabble in HCI oh yeah
that's right which is wonderful to me
I'm Steven Thacker is now i'm proud to
say working in the vibe group as a
manager of the view group visual user
experiences and he also dabbles on the
intersection of things technology
applications and information
visualization and apparently he's had
the privilege of kicking Bill Gates off
the stage at a conference you're going
to have to ask him about that later and
Andrew Glasner is no longer with us but
was in MSR for a long time and also in
product i remember you moved to product
and then came back right you're one of
those few who's tried that also in the
well-known in the computer graphics
community and originator and editor of
computer graphics gems excuse me a
series and an introduction to ray
tracing his most recent book is on
processing and he's done all kinds of
things including interactive fiction
writing and directing 3d I remember
wildtangent was in his history somehow
right the something yeah we worked with
you on that so I'm fascinating
background lots of books definitely hang
around and listen to these guys present
what they've been doing with girls
programming and processing hey
thanks a lot Mary so we're going to do
this a little informally this all
started primarily because we had girls
who have known each other essentially
since they were born and are now
classmates after many many years and we
summer came along and thought an
opportunity to kind of try to infect
them with things that we think about a
lot and this was our attempt at doing
this so most we're just going to talk
about the experience of doing this one
week class this past summer I should you
know preface it would say this is
something was completely new for us to
do and we'll try to share with you a few
things that we learned and in particular
if it's something that that you're
interested in doing your cells for a
group of kids we'd be happy afterwards
to talk to you about at more length and
give you everything that we did and help
you set something like that up so let's
see so first what were our goals in
doing this clearly at least the two of
us wanted to introduce programming to
these girls but importantly this had to
be fun it was in the summer they just
finished their school year of course we
wanted you know make this empowering for
them and a big goal also was to create
tangible artifacts we didn't want them
to just leave with some memory of some
programs of be able to carry something
with them then it's always important in
any of these little classes you can show
something to your parents at the end we
had no illusions that they were going to
walk out after after we can be
self-sufficient programmers but at the
same time we really also wanted to avoid
scaring them away wanted them to walk
out and hopefully think this was a fun
thing and then maybe as it came up later
in their course worker in their lives
they would have some sense of what was
going on so part of this by the way was
because what we wanted them to learn
this was not necessary an express wish
that they had they they would put up
with their fathers kind of talking about
how cool it is but not so much they're
their own great desire to do this yes I
should say we tried another thing
earlier on which was to do a robotics
class this one took place this this one
knows it at our house we had an
automatic at Steve's house that was
reasonably successful those boys and
girls and that's another reason why you
see the word art here what we did is we
had a week we did nine o'clock in the
morning till three in the afternoon
there were seven girls all having just
finished seventh grade going on to
eighth grade and they all knew each
other there at lakeside school you know
lakeside school and they were all in I
think all but one in the advanced math
class there and importantly two of them
were our daughters so this is not a sort
of a generic group of kids that just
came together and didn't know each other
says a lot of good dynamic going into it
yeah that's a really good question
because I think if we'd put out a call
we would have got a lot of competition
so we kind of hand-picked them but we
like we picked them sort of based upon
ones that got along not ones that were
oh my god they may be great at this it
was more it's a good group of people
that could yeah and also not ones where
prima donnas or well they're the parents
go so this will get you a head or
something it these were yeah so we'd be
hand-picked them I guess is its way to
guide it wasn't hard I think we asked
maybe one additional one and everybody
said oh yeah that'll be great let's
let's do it and actually it was a little
tricky because there were a lot others
that would like to do this but we didn't
really want to have more than seven in
fact I think we wanted to have six
originally and yet start out with sort
of an idea of six and ended up with
seven so so what do we do this was a it
was posed as a computer art camp as
opposed to programming camp to keywords
art so we geared this so that all the
projects would be visual
and essentially to have artifacts that
they could create and clearly had also
via camp which had a lot of downtime a
lot of time for them to just run around
we had imagined actually we have a park
not too far that they would just go out
and run around and and do a lot of other
things as well talk about we didn't end
up having a lot of downtime and that was
not our fault it really was their fault
because they just was very hard to get
them to to stop but anyway so we also as
we were going getting into this trying
to figure out what to do we talked to
lynn lanjut and she works with Luke
another guy named Llewellyn Falco and
they have been developed developing a
program they're down in California and
they actually came up here which was
great and gave us a whole sort of mini
class as if we were teaching they use
something called small basic which we
can talk about a little bit but what we
really got from there and a big thing
was this idea of always having them
program in pairs so in the beginning so
each day we would have them sit in pairs
and since we're seven or sometimes a
group of three and one person would be
sitting there at the keyboard typing the
other person would be kind of response
or telling them what to type and you
know it just made for a very nice
interaction and we alternated that a
little bit although they were fine with
just sort of mixing it up themselves
yeah and they yeah anyway we let them
sort of take the lead on a lot but the
other thing is at the in the afternoons
so they would create a program that
would do something something I could do
something with and then once they got it
going then they would spread out they
all have their own laptop it spread out
they'd all make their own art so it
wasn't sort of a it was a sort of team
effort to do the programming aspect but
then an individual effort to do to
create these artifacts and as you can
see all basically everyone had a laptop
I had to fit around our dining room
table and that's pretty much the
restriction
a seven maybe we could have actually
there was another chair here that wasn't
there at the moment they all had memory
sticks so they could share code that way
that was easy thing although in fact
they didn't do a whole lot of that
because they were more or less staying
kind of in lockstep until you know we'll
talk about what happened to her towards
the end we had a projector just
projecting up on to a clip a flip chart
another flip chart didn't use the flip
chart that much a little bit but often
Steve and I are standing down here and
and typing and they could see what we
were typing and could ask questions like
that then we had a nice color printer
would you use mostly on the last day
talk about that so made a bunch of other
choices one was to use processing and
this is probably one of the sort of the
touch eosin most important choices one
makes and you know we'll talk about why
we did that and also andrew is here and
I'll introduce him more at the end but
he just finished this book and we'll
talk more about that in a little while
but basically this is the language that
was made essentially for artists it was
a bunch of pros and cons I don't know p
Oates yeah again this was one of the
tougher decisions that we made because
it's it's got a terrible idea it really
is hard to debug and it's hard to use
but if you look out on the net and
you'll show you a whole bunch of
examples a lot of artists are using this
for installations for their own artwork
for visualizations and it was sort of
that promise of being able to create
exciting things that you know made us go
in this direction it was also pretty
easy for us to learn because it's really
you know based on job our video csharp
is oh so for us it was trivial and and
Michael and I spent quite a while before
hand going over how do we teach this and
that was actually a really interesting
experience because obviously we've been
programming for years and years and we
wanted to make something interesting but
that we could introduce slowly and then
we kept looks like oh but that's a hard
math thing oh but this is oh that's
really complicated so how do we
structure this and you'll see this more
but it was really helpful that we were
facile in the language
so that we can teach it yeah and I say
we had a lot of fun ok this is coming up
we spent a lot of time just sending
little programs back and forth it's so
cool how can we get them d how can we
simplify the concept down to to do that
and and we did look you know there's a
lot of work on teaching girls
programming there's this market called
Alice which is at Carnegie Mellon in
fact there's even a Alice for telling
stories which they've used for teaching
girls I think Mary actually helped
advise that that student that do but uh
and then there was a small basic which
is you know nice when I from Microsoft
but again we didn't see the compelling
artifacts right away and that's that's
kind of why we want this direction so
one problem was that we really wanted
them because it didn't have this nice
programming interface we didn't want to
bog them down with with syntax and so
essentially Steve and I were the the
auto debuggers right we were the you
know the sort of instant you just push
one of our buttons and we debug their
program before it's about word them and
it's you know syntax is a terrible thing
and it's too bad and you know there's
been there's a lot of tools that help
you in other language but not in
processing so often you know we somebody
would just go it's not working it's not
working and we'd be presented with
something look that looks like that we'd
say well sort of kind of subtly hint
it's nice to indent things and to do a
little bit so we'd say okay well how
about if we were to format it and then I
used but you know actually this line is
probably supposed to go inside the curly
brackets oh okay i just added that line
so you know we move it up and sure
enough things worked we didn't ask we
didn't sort of we never force them to
actually figure that out because you
know there were six other girls around
the table where it was working or you
know maybe five we're working in two are
going like hell Pelle Pelle Pelle and so
we would just go up and essentially fix
it and we'll talk a little bit later
about you know the pros and cons of
doing that but I think in the end it was
a good idea so the plan was to basically
spend a couple hours in the morning
writing some code
and then have a nice long lunch and then
come back after lunch and use the
program that they had made or maybe do
some modifications to that program and
we crafted basically the five days
something like this where the first day
in first two hours they're supposed to
write a complete paint program the
second day there was learned all about
Paul dynamics and be able to write a
fully sinful simulator a complete word
processor they were going to write on
Wednesday and a complete complete image
processing sweet on Thursday and you
think we're joking I can report renounce
you will confirm they in fact did all
four of those projects before lunch each
of those days so I think what we were
going to do next is talk about the paint
program a little bit and this is a
couple of the paintings that came out of
out of that day that day's work from a
couple of girls and figure the easiest
way to do it is that we're going to get
you guys to write paint programs while
we're here let's hope this works yes
exactly and we'll actually sort of do it
the way we did it in class which was
sort of Michael with any talking and
then I heard the other day we'd switch
to my so every processing program has
one function that starts out it's called
setup and this is a fully functional
program so they get them that they
actually typed this in and say well
every time you type something that's run
it and sure enough that's the program
what it does so you guys have any ideas
how to make it more interesting colored
spur well the first episode yeah see you
guys are so far down they were going
like oh that's an ugly gray if we change
there that color so we said all right
let's try you know about 10 see what
that does
and of course we can run it look it's a
darker color oh that's fun how I wanted
mine to be purple okay about 100-150 20
and two hundred and sure enough Hey look
purple Becker so why you know why did
that happen what are these numbers and
they're smart enough you know most of
them have thought about it you know I've
certainly taken a magnifying glass up
and show them how you know color makes
because I do computer graphics but
anyway let's go back to just making a 10
we actually challenged them at that
point just can anybody make yellow oh
yeah anyway make yellow so they just
were going crazy and they're running
around oh that's cool color and they
would run over to the other side of the
table to see what color they had made
and come back and you know instantly
there you're doing this oh that looks it
now every program has one other part one
other function called draw the nice
thing is set up runs when you start the
program draw will run every time you
ever eat every frame time okay and so
there's one function called ellipse and
put four numbers in there and let's just
try running that and see what it does
and sure enough there's a you know it
draws a little ball sort of explain what
an ellipse is a little bit for that so
what do we need to do to make a pink
program I mean that's interesting but
yes okay so should follow the mouse so
let's make it follow the mouse
let's write learn that
alright so this look like a paint
program yeah pretty much what should we
do next any ideas change the brush size
okay so where do you think sizes that
are in here so let's change it to 5050
locate
probably not what you meant right so
what else sorry yeah the third guy
wherever he goes first of all people
first thing they complained about was
this edge that was on there right so
there's a magic function called no
stroke and that will run and then as
Matt was saying we should figure out a
way to get it to get so this is where it
and say there's a thing called mouths
pressed and that's where you learn a
little format and sure enough you do
that and we're getting there we almost
have a they almost have a pink program
already right with you sir you need a
user interface okay so what do you want
to do with your user interface yeah all
right well let's do all that so we
didn't want to get into building user
interfaces and this is if I know there's
no do I toolkit with this language and
that's the real pain but we actually did
that at the very end it I'll talk about
make it out on Friday so why don't we
just bring in some code that was down
below now
alright
let's run this and now a couple of
things one is we introduced variables
obviously maybe we can go back and let's
go look at the code for a second yep so
somewhere up in here there's physical
variables it has rights week there's a
thing called fill for changing the color
reset the RGB and there's actually an
alpha for setting alpha this not sure
why we have the best stroke come in here
and then we use this basically this
thing if mouth actually can you go down
to the key press yeah essentially our
user interface was this go up a little
bit it says this key pressed so this was
our size we use you know these keys to
make the size bigger and smaller
similarly for our we used our capital R
B capital B and mg capital G so you
could just put whatever you wanted in
there to make different things you could
change it you could be pressing a key
while you're doing it can be changing
the color while you're doing it and you
know that was about another oh I don't
know I'd say bye and we didn't just give
them everything exactly what the time
you know we talked about each thing he
said what would you want to do we want
to be able to change the color we want
to be able to change the size and you
know kind of handed him alpha I don't
think they they came up with that but
pretty much by then they were just off
in fact at every step you know the key
was that they just suddenly they have
this incredible extra power with this
variable that they could change and they
would just sit there at our painting and
again just constantly running around to
see what they're doing and in this
pairing was really nice thing too
because a pair would say oh let's try
this or let's try that or these little
teams and they be building these
emigrants one team would do something
and they call the other one over and oh
that's cool and then they go back so we
could do something like that or
something different and you have each
other ideas there was a lot of ideas but
within the pairs and also between the
pairs so another thing here is there's a
function called save which will just
save the screen into a
into a PNG or a JPEG file or PDF even if
you would like it to and this is just a
little thing my daughter's name is Elena
was to make the file always be unique so
whenever they hit tab it would just
generate a unique file name starting
with Lena and would just write out that
thing so again you could be painting you
save in painting and save it to do
different things and the key thing here
was that while we gave them some of this
hand-holding at the beginning they
really did start sort of improvising on
these things you know they'd get the
concept of the variables pretty quickly
and then oh this is how we can change
the size smaller and this is how we can
do the other things ok so yep general
language question so did you explain the
language of front or was it also just in
time and did you like minimal
explanations or did you try and
generalize like I did statement takes
over yeah you know this was something we
toyed with a lot and it would seem
pretty clear in you know especially when
talking about they weren't interested in
understanding the syntax at first except
if it gave them benefit so when we added
the if statement for the mouse pressed
then ah now I understand it and that
everyday really got it and the same
thing we did this sort of variables and
I know you're Michael's thinking about
okay letter envelope boxes we sort of
kind of did that and yeah they just got
and so some of the things we were really
impressed that they just got right away
and again we didn't do we you know we
were thinking beforehand we're going to
recursive functions and all these other
things so we probably should I show you
for a close that there's another
function there that's called random
which we made liberal use of and in this
for example this is a noon so they wrote
the basic paint program then the
afternoon I'll just open that again so
we're going so you scroll down yeah
anytime I need to UM so the afternoon
they they wrote fancy brushes and they
each did these on their own and so
essentially what they did so I'd like to
do something like this could I do this
and then we'd work sort of one-on-one
them two to make a fancy brush so yeah
so some of them are basically would
would most of that one aren't the road
no one remember anyway they would sort
of randomly perturb the brush and
randomly perturb the color and then just
you know sort of have this kind of
airbrush e thing and they each did very
different ones yeah so it's one of the
brushes again just by hitting a number
on the keypad you switch which brush
you're using and I don't know if any of
you have encountered kid picks but a lot
of our kids hadn't kind of grew up doing
kid picks and they felt so wow I'm doing
my own kid pics and they kept on adding
new kinds of brushes and they didn't do
sound effects for erasing things but was
part of that so here's a couple of the
pictures that that they generated in
this process this one was from that
brush that that you just saw this was
actually the very simple brush but they
literally would add sort of rounders of
color and they'd be changing the size as
they're painting and changing color that
was kind of fun because actually had two
people pull on the claw no use it was
really was really fun to see and at this
point I just want to show you a very
short little video which i think i
queued up already so this this is about
literally three hours into their life of
programming so i think this happened
just shortly after lunch they were back
and starting to to modify some things it
just kind of gives you a sense of its
kind of
it's perfect ribs and then the lipstick
look wrecked you just do so hi I need to
grab a new trend of integration today
took the exact amount plus s so you get
the idea you know one of them is figured
something out and the other ones
starting to sort of job we we spent uh
you know I expected us to be up there
kind of constantly running around at by
the time you know literally a couple
hours into this entire process we were
tourists hit at night but they know what
and periodically you know someone would
like look over and go something's not
working you'd go over and you know
change add a semicolon I mean that was
that became our life was just adding
semicolon so it really was it was really
it's really fun okay so the second day
and we're not going to take quite as
long in each day but we did vol dynamics
but I think what we'll do is we'll try
to at least get started on this one as
well and do the same thing okay so
here's our basic so what's this program
going to do well let's run it and find
out so looks just like the last one
right but now instead of having the
mouse move the ball around mouse move
the brush around now will call the ball
so what do you have to do to make ball
dynamics right what did you learn in
physics 101 what do we need one spot
what is forced cause movement which is
yeah all right so let's add a couple of
things will have the physician and no
sure yes speed sure sure how about a
couple more want to call them DX for
velocity of course yeah dy4
yeah sure fun what add some acceleration
while we're at it something something
just set those 20 for now
right and cut where are those going to
go well that's the position right and
all right and actually we would have
them run like this and it was like oh
it's not moving at all yeah okay so what
should we do so what should we do so
we're gonna have good just good sub x
equals x plus DX and white y plus B why
what's good and that took a little while
for them just so so we really say so
what's going to happen now and they're
all going no so a lot of times we'd give
them something like this and or they
would say we have to add that to get it
to move but we'd probably give them that
and then really wait until they guessed
what's going to happen so let's try it
what is good OH what's going to happen
oops think yeah it's gone all right so
let's go back when we up the velocity a
little bit just to make it fun all right
and it's rotted a gun where again we
just kind of run at all done faster so
now what do we got it too so how are you
gonna do that okay anyway so we said you
know if x is greater than we have this
number up here from over the size of the
screen and we they what do we need to do
anybody have an idea negate the velocity
really good this one that was not the
first guess if it was nothing a lot of
people with deseo let's set it back to
something and it would that wasn't quite
right and then someone so I could stop
it let's try running that let's see what
that does who worked Oh went off bomb so
we go on you know to do the bottom the
other side's well let's add one we had
acceleration right now let's just set a
a why to be one what's going to happen
now nothing
we added these yeah good hoschton what
happen there well let's let's just do
this one day if Y is greater than 600 y
equals of ya think we should i eat a why
a little smaller to
I'll go amazing away all right so for
long we've got you know literally this
is again you know they've got this and
now can we do with strike running one of
these oops let's try this one oh this
belt so this one took a little
hand-holding but not too much and said
if you can make one ball you can make a
whole bunch of them and then you know
question how are we going to make art
out of this anybody got an idea what's
the night you had no idea how to make
this into some cool art thing one line
change hmm oh yeah you could just hit
you can just keep hitting hitting print
but let that's what's going to happen if
we comment out this line that's right
yeah all right so you can start to see
where they'll start going wild oh let's
be able to change this lets me go change
that and again oh yeah so then in the
afternoon we said what do you want to do
now should we extend it make it so you
can change the color and make so you can
change change the forces and they're
going ooh let's make let's make a pong
game like yeah sure why not yeah I don't
know maybe they'd seen it in flash game
oh let's make a game yeah just make a
game you know we can be triggered
something that so in fact they wrote
this thing and if I keep their
better playing it we could like and
you'll notice they make this is too easy
after a while so I said all right how
about every time we did you know keeping
score up here every time you hits an
interval of 5 the paddle gets a little
bit smaller and then to make it a little
more difficult one thing you'll notice
it's adding a little random perturbation
actually to the velocity in here so it
goodness yeah right actually they ended
up playing this game of color and anyway
so they were just you know loves
effectively a game so all this really is
not much difference between a paint
program in a pong game and by the way
the pong game was not something that we
planned out beforehand so while they
were eating lunch bikol and I work
well they wanted to make a game they
said that before they broke for lunch
can we do this so very quickly we just
did it and then they we did the
enhancements with them afterwards and
again it was nice to have the structure
from them to go so that was day two so
again by the first day they had written
up complete paying program second day
they had written a a you know whole
simulator in ball dynamics these are
some of the art that came out of out of
that again you can see by setting
different kinds of parameters and
changing the opacity in this one or
whatever and again as things were going
on they would keep hitting the six
little tab and could record these images
third day was was fun it was a little
less programming we decide to write a
word processor and we did in fact spend
a little time the morning to get them to
be able to fill literally type and hit
spaces and then to do backspace so she
was a trick and to get it to wrap down
to the next line using fonts and then so
they got that now he said let's why
don't we make our own font you guys
could just make it and sort of have this
idea that they would go out and maybe
find some sticks or trees or or some way
to do it but turned out to be really big
I think you know what are we going to do
maybe we could get some silverware out
or whatever anyway decided to use what
they had and just gave him a camera and
this they spent probably two hours
making this font because it wasn't right
and they had to run back up and they
were you know trying to do this but
anyway eventually they constructed this
font i think in one picture of someone's
shirt was a little bit up and there's no
no we gotta take that picture out it
went back down and take that picture
again and um so yeah it was a it was a
in some ways a quieter day on the
programming front but you know i think
they got the idea of you know the
complexities of being able to hit
backspace and being able to erase
something and keep track of where the
cursor was and you know got got that
through by the end of the day they had
pretty much warned themselves out and
didn't end up writing a whole lot
imagine these little poems as these
things but we didn't get any yeah
wonderful poet and just the lighting
didn't quite work out nicely so that's
good hard hard to read I don't know you
know even read this as a couple of girls
an akan and Lena gecko and my daughter
you know are awesome it says anyway so
that was the third day and on the fourth
day we eat I'd do image processing
there's a lot of really wonderful makes
it very easy to bring in an image and to
create an image and just to show you
some of the artifacts they created this
is a sm all to do self-portrait so the
first thing they did is took the camera
and took pictures of each other so they
could bring in a picture of themselves
and use that as as the backdrop and then
on this one all it is is literally
randomly picking a pixel and moving it
either up one or to the left one or down
or to the right one just so using random
picking it pick a pixel and move it move
it one pixel in some direction and then
you just let it run its really fun you
just kind of starts out there and as it
goes it just starts buzzing at right or
we wrote another one called melts that
just kind of takes the pixels and they
start trying to dripping down the screen
this one is very similar it's it except
instead of a you know a particular pixel
it takes a little square and does the
same thing just lose it perturbs it
randomly about we did a couple of other
just real simple things like doing a
negative or talked about what the
negative of color was you know get RGB
what is the negative of that we did a
solarization thing to which is kind of
just making sort of half of the of the
other thing negative no you had a lot of
fun with that and then this one's a
little different we ended up combining
the paint program with sort of an image
program so this is kind of scratch
painting in a way essentially what you
do is you move the mouse around the
screen and it picked up the color from
the underlying image and put a square a
rectangle that color if you were moving
quickly it would make it bigger if you
made it the quicker you were moving it
the bigger the square it would make
so you could really do a lot of fun
things with that they had a lot of fun
with this this sequence actually making
things would turn it to be a very
relatively small amount of programming I
did a lot of did a lot of help in
providing this last one she created
anyway it was just really nice thing the
last day we did a little bit of user
interface we went back to the the paint
program and actually had them draw a
little red green and blue bars that you
could slide the mouse over to to do
pickin and you had a little square that
showed the color and that was quite
interesting trying to work with him they
were very good at at coming up with how
to do it but kind of could see after the
four days a sort of really powerful
stuff happening creating user interfaces
you know really kind of guy also had a
missed this last day because I was
leaving the next day for Brazil so
Michael had to take this woman on his
own anyway so we didn't do that for very
long but we actually built that the
little three sliders but most of the
rest of the day we spent printing out
the results a maid and I got a bunch of
gnats that they could sort of frame some
of them and we just pulled all the stuff
off the walls in our dining room in and
started gluing things all over the walls
and and they really had a great time you
know one of them said oh this wall is
going to have this theme and this was
going to have that theme and and you
know each couple of girls working on
this wall on that wall so that when
their parents came to pick them up in
the afternoon they could you know see
what we had done over the week and then
rip them off the walls to take to take
home so how do we do on our goals two of
these goals I think we did quite well to
the goals were somewhat in conflict
right we want it to be empowering but we
really didn't expect to make themselves
you know self-sufficient programmers
which is really kind of an empowering
thing so it's hard to say and I still
struggle with this a little bit should
we have gone slower and really you know
taught them some
syntax or sort of what was really
happening what a semicolon really kind
of mint and curly brackets and you know
what what declaring variables and you
know I think I'm still glad we did it
this way but but clearly none of them
could walk out of there right and sit
down and just and it was a camp so there
wasn't I mean I think some of this
needed to sort of percolate in their
heads begin a homework like assignment
where they had to now generate it on
their own without watching or whatever
but again that really wasn't the goal
the goal was I did this once it wasn't
hard I could do this again and in fact
they're the various times in the class
and they're in a school where they might
have to do some sort of repetitive task
and now not just like she said you know
we could do a program for this say we
could add more time because they had a
whole that homework assignment which was
what's the the thousandth term in this
series recto some they're doing
mathematical series and question of
what's the thousandth term in it yeah so
yeah any of the nights and actually
continue
no I don't didn't hear about that I know
a lot of them took things home and
showed their parents what they were
doing I didn't really get reports of
them doing a lot of modification of it
later on even after class yeah like we
yeah very little yeah these girls have
like facebook or anything today this is
artifacts make make it outside to their
social um I know that my daughter didn't
start doing Facebook until actually the
end of this summer just just exactly the
time and I don't know about the other
ones yes I think it's interesting what
you just said and I'm wondering how
you're going to measure the impact for
them because I think that's a great but
that one of the kids said oh we could
you know we could create a program to
solve this because that is a huge leap
that they're now saying how r
programming could help them a night is
relevant to their lives because that's
when the huge issues yeah so I'd say the
jury is really out on you know work we
did this as a one-off or not really
planning to do an evaluation you know we
will see it in our own girls on what we
are planning to go to the eighth grade
math teacher and talk to him about this
and see if he wants to do something
similar in his classes here yeah he's
been teaching it looks like forever and
they used to do he said they used to do
some programming but now there's so many
programs that that are already usable
you don't have to use sort of had too
many years ago so me maybe we'll get
that introduced back in so one goal for
sure we were successful at and and that
was it really you it was super fun I
mean it can't tell you the number of
times when whence they just leave with
it that is just so cool you don't
everybody rush around and those moments
least you know for me rep just
phenomenally Amy and we just showed one
of those those little videos there were
a lot of your pictures you didn't take a
video camera out enough but there were
so many of these things just how i wish
we'd captured that yeah yeah and one of
the one of the girls really was
clearly just kind of got it at some
point and was running around and just
you know helping the other ones out and
it was really it really was really was
nice so with that I want to introduce
Andrew Andrew you kept the introduction
from Mary and he's written this
wonderful book and I know I encouraged
him to actually bring a box of these
books with him so if you're interested
in in one of these books talk to him
after and I'm sure he can make some
arrangements for you to to purchase one
but era I wanted just let Andrew talk
for comments about his book in his
passion for for processing thanks
Michael yes if you want to buy books I
know a guy we can make a deal Michael
actually asked me to do two things and
we've switched can we switch back to the
previous laptop so I wanted to do two
things one was to talk about what other
people have done with processing and
show you why I think it's an interesting
language and then I'll talk a little bit
about what I learned writing this book
and then developing a course based on it
so the way I got into processing um was
a couple of years ago I was giving a
talk at siggraph on the basics of
computer graphics which I've done from
like 20 years and it's always been on 3d
graphics I thought oh I should do
something on 2d and i served made a list
of the usual suspects and I looked at
flash and hours since week and squonk
and scratching all the different
languages and you know I thought okay
they're all good 2d languages now just
pick one and then I ran across the web
site of an artist and his website blew
me away actually let's just jump right
to it his name is Jared Tarbell we have
to switch to the
here we are okay so his name is Jared
Tarbell and he's got a number of
websites this is complexification net
and let's go to hear I just want to show
you some of these programs he's written
in processing and when I saw these I
thought wow okay wait there's something
going on here this is a natural running
program let's go ahead and run it I
launched the medium-sized applet and now
it's running it's it's driving itself
off of random numbers but I looked at
this and I said holy smokes there is
something going on here this is not just
a little random toy applic thing there's
Wow and I wanted to learn processing so
in the hands of somebody who really
knows what he's doing processing can do
amazing stuff let me just show you a
couple of other pieces from chora
Tarbell who I have never met by the way
but I have exchanged email with and he's
a very nice guy and all of these are on
the web I'm running live web pages here
and one thing you may notice is in the
bottom there's a source code link when
you write an applet in processing it's a
one click menu choice to say export you
export it it makes an applet it makes a
web page it makes all sorts of stuff
associated with the web page so that the
applet will run makes a link back to
processing if you haven't downloaded it
and it gives you a link to the source
code the idea is that heck the code
should be there you don't have to
obviously you can edit that out but part
of the aesthetics of the community is we
share our code and it's wonderful of
course because that's how you learn what
other people are doing this is a really
interesting applet what he's got is a
number of moving circles that they're
hidden you can't see them what he's
drawing is the places where the circles
overlap and so you get a nice little
bright white dot where the circles cross
on each other it's just gorgeous if the
room was a little darker I think I would
look even prettier he has a version of
this where he traces the curves and
that's what this applet does here this
is the very same thing only instead of
clearing the screen each time it's
remembering you know it's just a
avoiding those intersection points and
you know by golly they start to really
look interesting he's also invented a
really beautiful line drawing technique
which he calls a sand painter which he's
using here which I just fell in love
with and I've used a few times with his
permission and initially it was
mysterious to me as to how it worked i
opened up his code figured out what he
was doing changed it to make it the way
I liked it and now I use it as just
another primitive let me show you a
couple of other things he's done so this
is what made me fall in love with
processing when I realized it could do
stuff like this and it was just a single
click you could export it to the web is
a sort of a fractal-like thing it it's
different every time so sometimes you
get really beautiful ones and sometimes
you don't uh so I also looked at a lot
of other languages and I'm not putting
them down but I had to pick one and for
the ease of programming and the quality
of the visuals I chose processing for
that class and it worked out very nicely
people really dug it it's one more I
want to show you a bubble chamber it's
just really a sweet applet own there are
four kinds of particles and they kind of
their flying around inside a Collider
let's say do I have to you know there we
go
so as you saw you saw the Java thing
come up these are all what happens a
processing sits on top of Java it looks
like a subset of Java and it sort of is
but there are differences too so it is
not strictly a subset of Java there's a
whole lot of overlap but there's some
processing commands that don't exist in
Java some Java commands have been
tweaked and changed in subtle ways but
it was designed to let you crank out
this kind of stuff real fast let me
notice that there are these nice and
bossing effects I mean it's really
really dirt simple and the source code
is there and one of the ways i learned
processing was looking at the source
code for this thing in fact won't we
bring it up just you can see what it
looks like here all these examples of
pictures he's made I mean how can you
not fall in love with this oh okay so
we're not getting it right now but the
source code is out there so I fell in
love with this thing and I thought okay
this is great when I'm when I'm off to
give my class at siggraph let's say you
can't blow this up no so i thought when
i'm off to give my question siggraph
i'll talk about processing for 10 or 15
minutes so i did that and people loved
it and so the following year I thought
well I'll talk about processing again
but you know I need to write some
lecture notes or something and I went to
the coffee shop and I opened up the
laptop and I figured okay I'll I'll bang
out three or five pages of lecture notes
and about five weeks later I had a
thousand-page book because it just
happens that way sometimes so okay I had
this book I'm processing the book I
chose to do it in a weird way and in
fact there's a lot of overlap with what
Michael and Steven did the book is not
like a regular programming book and I've
got nothing against regular programming
books I've read a million we all have
their great but this was meant to be for
artists the idea was this is people like
this guy who are making art
installations I don't think that this
guy cares much about programming at all
he wants to make pictures like this and
you know what getting out of paint brush
and getting out you know your paints and
doing that that's one way to go but if
want to make a hundred of them in with
variations computers the way to go and
so you got to learn that tool well that
was the idea of the book was let's help
people learn that tool the the the
primary thought behind the book was
programming is not interesting in and of
itself I'm not coming to you because you
want to learn to program you don't care
about it you want to make art and I
happen to have a tool that does it so
I'm going to teach you the tool but the
whole reason is that you can make art
and you know what if processing was a
system for teaching otters to roll
around in paint and then roll around on
a canvas and that made the pictures that
we could make here I would have taught
you how to train otters it's not the
programming it's them it's where it gets
you so that was the first thought and I
thought okay how can I do that and went
through the same service of process that
these guys did it say it all right what
most programming books do is is not
universally but often their depth first
you know here's here's the structure of
the if statement here's the syntax
here's the boolean here are the boolean
types you know here's how to evaluate a
boolean here's what happens if you do an
assignment within a boolean you know you
get into all this detail furthermore a
lot of programming books because they
expect some sophistication from you will
present you with syntactical stuff and
grammatical stuff knowing that you know
why it's there and I figured people new
to programming they don't know why and
furthermore they don't care so my
thought was I'm going to very much like
what they did only without prior
collusion I said you know what I'm going
to sort of set up these little projects
that we want to do and i'm going to say
how can we possibly do this oh my gosh
we need something that can like make a
choice by golly it exists it's called an
if statement it looks like this let's
use it and i didn't get into the detail
and the idea of the book was each time
we talk about something we just glanced
off of it we just sort of touch it and
move away we learnt just what we need to
know and later when we need to know more
we'll come back to it then we'll come
back to it again we'll come back to
again and by kissing it many times
threat the course of the book
we will come to know this thing in its
entirety that has a number of benefits
one is you know gets logged down with
tons of detail second is you get to
integrate the information as you go
third is accumulated mastery right it's
not like oh my gosh we're going to spend
three days learning about if statements
we've never even heard of a while loop
no spend five minutes on if and five
minutes on variables and five minutes on
wiles and we can do stuff uh the the
second approach that I took with the
book was leave in the bugs I wrote
dozens and dozens of programs for this
book and I took a snapshot every time I
added anything significant five lines
changed the data structure I would just
I was sitting there in the coffee shop I
didn't even realize I was going to use
it I just thought I was making a trail
of breadcrumbs for myself and I would
you know make a little change run it oh
i left the typo snapshot this code
stick this I'd fix the bug run it got it
grab a snapshot and so I had dozens of
snapshots for every program and they're
all in the book because that's how you
program another programming books do
that right they say you know here's how
to make a bank transaction system yo and
they break it down into the modules and
show you the modules and then you have
20 pager code listings and you're done
and nobody writes code that way you
write five lines you run them they break
you fix them you run them it works you
save it so I thought this is this is
what real programming is why pretend
it's anything else and so in the book
there are figures every time I develop a
program I'll show you a couple of these
programs in fact let's let's go to one
right right now okay so let's switch the
other computer police thank you and it
looks like oh
so here's a little processing program we
didn't talk about type and I thought I
would just open with a little typography
processing can do to can do type so I'll
show you a couple of programs that I
wrote for the book and then I'll talk
about how how they got developed so
let's go to group one so one of the
things I did a few times the book is I'm
a postcards from other planets so every
time you run this applet you get a
different post card so let's run it a
couple times and it's there all the
sword is the same you know they're all
winter scenes on a you know world with
with sort of puff ball trees but there
are many many layers there's all kinds
of stuff happening here right the snow
is reflecting this the Sun the Sun is
coming through the trees there's
illumination on the trees or coerce
stuff going on there's actually a whole
lot of stuff going on well in the book
there are probably I'm guessing 60
versions of this program and they're all
online I mean oh I don't miss them all
obviously but they're all up there on
the website from the very beginning from
the from the first call that just says
make us screen 600 x 600 to the next
line three more lines to five more lines
including all the broken ones and so
every processing generated figure in the
book and there are like eight hundred of
them every single one in the caption
contains the URL of the code that made
that picture even the ones that are
horrible and broken even the ones that
comes out it's like oh my gosh my
picture went black saves the URL you can
run that code regenerate the black
picture for yourself and you can fix it
yourself if you want where you can see
how i fixed it so i thought this was an
important learning tool
they're the book is the annotation in
some sense I deliberately night auct
about this quite a lot in the book the
and it was a real do as I say not as I
do there the code is largely uncommented
uh and it just has to be that way or
just gets overwhelming in a book to have
all those listings they double in size
with comments ok screen went black hair
did you put scream of black associated
with that Samsung I when it wasn't
obvious what was going wrong but yes in
the discussion you know if you're
reading along in the book I'll say okay
now we'll set V equals three let's try
it out well that's wrong what went wrong
well we have a loop and ba ba ba and I
talked about my thought process in
trying to fix it and in fact as happens
sometimes I couldn't find the bug right
away I went after the wrong things
sometimes in fact in one place I
couldn't find the bug and so I built
this whole extra bunch of code to
demonstrate things to show me what was
going wrong somewhere else that code had
a bug in it well it's all there in the
book because that's what it's really
like the program I was trying to
demystify the process so yes if you're
reading along you're probably thinking
this guy doesn't know how to program
worth beans because nobody else has
these problems but I figured put it all
out there because that's real life let
me just show you a couple of quick other
little little program so you get a
feeling for the sorts of things we do in
the book so that was actually one of the
more complicated ones let me show you
another another of the complex ones and
I'll show you a few of the simple ones
one of the beautiful things about
programming in processing is you can do
really complicated things with really
small programs because it's got all the
right geometric primitives built in and
so these are little grains of sand and
they're falling down and they're being
blown around by fans and if we let this
run over time we got some very beautiful
snapshots let me show you two others
Group one spin cubes
I wanted to show you the processing can
also do 3d it's not it's not a real big
3d program that's not its real strength
its strength is 2d but this is 3d and
it's running and it's all native to
processing it's all built in it's
actually talking to OpenGL but you don't
have to learn any OpenGL and as most of
you have probably guessed what I have
here is a grid of cubes and I have a
different picture pasted on each side of
the cubes and I'm just I have several
different patterns for turning the cubes
over time to reveal a picture and in
fact one thing I'm doing I have many
more than six pictures and so after each
transition I change the picture that's
on the back face so we mix up the photos
so there's 3d let me show you a really
simple example of something in 2d really
short bit of code group 2 set 1 wheels
ok so here's the whole program I'm about
to show you this took that's the whole
program I'm about to run this took one
commercial break during Colbert Report
one night I'm watching colbert had an
idea by the time the commercial break
was done the program was finished and it
does this
no know about you but I love this stuff
I mean I could watch this for a really
long time and fit it with the numbers
and change the number of rings and
change how they spin and change though
the phase relationships between the
Rings and you can just play with this
thing for a very long time and this is
the kind of thing that prompted me to
think yeah this is worth talking about
this is worth teaching and again stop
that there's the whole code and it's all
the stuff that you guys just saw in fact
we can Walter it real quickly I set up a
bunch of floats couple colors they're
set up which we saw before right I
create a creative window 400 by 400 and
turn on anti-aliasing here's the code
that gets evaluated every every frame
clear the background set up a couple
variables run through loop I fill in I
set a fill color I draw an ellipse I
said another fill color so basically
what I'm doing is I draw say it an
orange circle and I cut it in half and I
draw blue semi circle and then I get
smaller and rotate draw an orange circle
and a blue semi circle get smaller
rotate that's it and that's all that's
happening here the radius is getting
smaller turning do that change the
starting angle and Delta on each frame
that's the whole program cool now could
you do this with all sorts of other
programs absolutely i mean there are
lots of programming languages out there
that can do this for me the beauty of
processing is it's just that easy you
just knock it out although as Michael
and Steven said the IDE is beyond awful
there's nothing to it its bare bones if
this doesn't run you start putting in
print statements which is ridiculous um
now there are external ideas that you
can use for processing but the native
has like no debugging abilities so I
want to wrap up so I was talking to a
couple of people about this book and
they were my target audience designers
who wanted to learn how to do this kind
of thing for their art to make museum
kiosks to make interactive installations
if you go to almost any Museum you will
see tons of processing stuff all over
it is the is the mechanism of choice for
visual artists who want to do the work
themselves they don't want to learn
flash later when learn after effects
they this gives them the tool so i
speaking somebody who wanted to do this
i said oh it's great I you know perfect
timing i just wrote a book and her
reaction was well yeah but where can i
find the videos said well no i haven't
done any videos i wrote this book yeah
but you know there's a website like
youtube right where you have the videos
in the book well this conversation went
on for a while and i realized my target
audience doesn't read books I just wrote
this thousand-page book and it's
beautiful and I fell in love with it
when I saw it and there you know they
want the YouTube URL well this happened
a few times so I decided okay I'll teach
online so I'm now taking the material
from that book and a lot of additional
material and I'm using it to teach an
online course which I'm now putting
together and putting the other a huge
website the course is going to have just
dozens and dozens of little videos and
each week I give you a little path like
like jumping from one lily pad to the
next through a part of the world and so
you know if you want to learn more about
recursive recursive programs there's a
lily pad for that but I don't talk about
it because it's not on the main path but
it's there if you want it and so every
week I will sign homework people do
their homework and I'll give them back
feedback i'll record a new video that
talks about what they've done in their
homework and uh I talk about everything
from the code formatting to the to the
color choices to the aesthetics of the
piece the how things move to you know
the actual implementation and then I
riff on it I say okay given the code
that you wrote here's another place we
can take it I actually have done a test
run of this course live with a couple of
people over a course of several weeks
and learned a couple of interesting
things one was they love the feedback
and people I was a little concerned that
people would say you're going to take
I program you can take my work and
change it and extend it and in fact they
love that you know they send you a thing
with four balls they're coming together
I actually have that but I'll skip it
for now but I can show it to you if
anyone wants to see it and I say okay
well you could take that and enhance it
you know many balls coming in fighting
and rotating around as they move and
they love that they say that's where I
can go next time um second thing is they
really like this business of being able
to revisit a node being able to say oh
wait there's this one little thing I
don't get I can always go back and check
it again so that's nice thing about
having little videos the third thing is
they won't read the book the first thing
we did when we sat down to give this
course as I sold them each a copy of the
book and they were happy to have it in
the middle it became clear to me they
would not open it they would write to me
and they say I and has us and such work
soon but Papa Papa Papa both and I would
be right back and I'd say well no
worries from page 315 2 318 I talk about
exactly that there's a discussion
there's figures there's example code I
sweated bullets on it check out page 315
and they break back obviously having not
taken a look so yeah but I don't see how
the data that the doubled up and we'd go
back two or three times and I finally
when I realized they will not open the
book basically I would transcribe what
was in the book is it's part of my
learning process and I didn't do it
verbatim because I didn't have no figure
18 3 I would just say see the screenshot
right and I would basically with a
little bit of change type in what was in
the book age is an email that be would
read that was fine and they were
grateful for it oh thank you that
explains everything so the for me the
lesson is you got to do in a video
because that's what they want and you
have to give your audience the
information they want the way they want
it so I have a bunch of books if anyone
wants to see them and we can talk about
this course which I hope will be live in
a few months
anyway so Andres got some books of your
ex it'd fit any reaction doing anything
remotely like this you know where to
find us and happy to just give you all
the code obviously there's way more code
than we can give you out there on the
web and other projects and you know we
got a lot actually got a lot of
inspiration just going through the index
in Andrews book we got a very early copy
before we did the course and true you
know some of the ideas out of there so
good test for that yeah girls were what
about 13 years older Jeff yeah young
very good question yeah um you know this
was actually in our thinking a lot as
we're designing some of the projects
because some of them Mighty Mouse math
or Craig or y'all could do that so I
think we ended up some of the things
where we actually have done maybe a
couple years earlier I know that we've
done stuff individually with our
daughters quite a bit early
yeah i would say but i would say a
couple years earlier we've been fine you
know now we don't really know what
fifteen-year-old girls are like but I'm
going to guess that that might be too
late judging from what thirteen and a
half going on 14 is getting to be like
have to remember their daughters too yes
I had a question about why you did the
robotics gave with boys and girls and
then you decided to do the artist what
was your learning from the robotics and
they do decide on art
there were a couple things one of which
was that a lot of times they want to do
stuff there was too hard to express the
bodies I remember you know let's take it
juggle the first things that they wanted
to do and I ok actually learned do
something a little bit more expressive
than was possible in the confines of the
robot and that was again why we chose
some of pain stuff and that's also why
we didn't choose this sort of
programming with Alice I guess alice is
great for doing certain things that he
worried a little bit constraint to this
3d environment that you did a warning to
three because are you aware there's a
huge debate in sort of the k-12
community about the entry pass you know
robotics versus canoe versus tragic
cetera and I love your immersive
approach and like your look is all about
tinkering if my hypothesis is that
tinkering immersion and fun are the way
to attract kids and you know fifteenth's
too late you know it if your God ok and
you might be too early but you know our
GT bringing fun I've grown up over 25
years of you know computer graphics
starting from when nobody had ever even
seen a picture on the screen to when we
first saw an actual picture come up on a
screen you know a digital image come up
on the screen and then getting into 3d
and 3d lighting and 3d animation and the
last 15 years I've been going no more 3d
I'm going to go back to to to do more
that i'm going to start from photos
which is why i'm kind of envision and
just you realize after going down that
path to d is wonderful I mean it's just
you know paints on up canvas is a great
thing
and just start there so yeah and we do
know some friends that have gotten in
via the robotics room David Pekerman his
son as really into what to do doing that
and he loved that but it just it never
clicked we found partly also we were
doing this online kind of course that
was trying to be developed from people
at MIT right so he actually had them on
video and got a lot of technical things
and the particular project in this class
was to create this little garden and so
they had all these pipe cleaners and
they're making little things out of it
and you know again you sort of saw the
girls just totally spend all their time
building these little flowers and things
out of pipe cleaners and and a little
plastic bits right and you know the guys
were like making little little catapults
and it was ok and it was also kind of
removed from the program and stuff yeah
so like I go up and open this up and it
does this and welcome done and they
didn't really embellish in that
direction here notion of like liver yep
another question it I read the original
book on process how long ago and it done
and what a beautiful thing it's a shame
it's got to carry the weight of Java
along with that book I would mentioned
it's ten times as bad for 13 year olds
hope that you got the semicolon fetish
to deal with what would what would have
made this better for purely programming
language going to be not that that is so
the processing primitives hope it just
yeah somebody write a nice ID nice
development environment around you don't
think java would have been a problem if
there'd been a nice way yeah yeah we
looked at these small basic and once you
said it and that's very nice because it
doesn't tell us that it does seven
cloning and dead to get all the other
things that just makes it such that you
can't make as much a mistake it tells
you what the mistake is here at you it
gives you choices you know do you want
you know this is Italy pick one or no
yeah although that might have I'm not
sure how well how flexible it would be
too yeah I think it would at least help
with all the syntactic lawyers yeah you
know it's a fine line right if you get
more and more and more help with auto
you know syntax fill in then you know
your flexibility starts feeling a little
constraint because it's start to go
outside of that
you know how to help you anymore but
yeah some of that would have gone a long
way maybe just seems ridiculous to me to
teach a thirteen-year-old to declare a
variable yes just like a fetus or so we
kind of worried about that they it
seemed to not bother them aside you did
this way they were learning all he said
that fine I mean the highest thing was
this sort of scoping of the parentheses
around all the pins yeah I need another
variable so i just copied it some other
her it's really just by example yeah
yeah I mean I maybe it would have been
better to take something that was just
uh Python or something we even have a
site yeah we talked a lot about show
this show I invited you considered that
because as you know python is really
good fun language to do right but it did
Matt the other thing about possibly we
didn't really talk about besides the
artistic community there's tons and tons
of libraries out there for doing all
sorts of other face for doing 3d we're
doing Arduino on an hasta is really into
trying to do some sewing and stitching
and she really wants to like rustling
because she wants to be able to program
those what community does
yes we've been actually talking to
Austin we have another there's a student
we fill advise from u-dub Eric up down
adobe in San Francisco has been getting
into these are doing a little boards
passion so I've been contemplating
trying to do a
passion this little argument blinky
lights you know dresses and shirts with
blinky lights and think maybe this next
summer
the next thing to do
just curious why I thought 15 is too
late I we don't know you know we don't
know have we have 13 year old it was no
there's this point you can be considered
as he just kind of take the victor there
was this you're gonna claim a whole week
of my summer yeah and force you to do
this anyway all right here we follow up
with this as much as you like I fell in
a book there's some talk to Andrew